here's what would happen if you drank  snake venom snake venom is not the same  as poison if you swallowed it your  stomach acids and digestive enzymes  would likely break it down but it  wouldn't be harmless if you ingested  neurotoxic Venom the Venom would start  to block or over stimulate your nervous  system this could lead to reduced eye  movement droopy eyelids and difficulty  speaking it might take weeks for your  nerves to repair themselves and it would  leave you unable to breathe without  external support if you drank enough of  this Venom to disrupt the chemical  signals that are sent between your  neurons it will leave you paralyzed it  could even kill you if you ingested  hemotoxic Venom and it made its way into  your bloodstream it would primarily  impact your blood and heart this could  lead to Serious internal bleeding blood  clots or heart failure so